thank you very much for talking to us um
obviously two years
in the making this is a huge project for
you
why did you decide that a prize like
this was the
best way to to bring about the change
that you want to create
so the earthshot prize as you said has
been two years in the making
we very much felt that uh an optimistic
prize to try and turn the narrative
around
um the pessimism and the negativity
around the climate
was the best way forward to try to find
some solutions so the asteroid prize
itself is really a way
of of elevating people's voices and
solutions that may be out there
that we've never heard of or haven't had
the chance to scale up
so it's really the most prestigious
global environmental prize you can
imagine
and it is truly global we've got a prize
council that spans the entire globe
and we've got scientific experts and
panels and people who are going to
filter through
a number of these solutions to try and
really tackle some of those
greatest environmental though when the
world
challenges
at this tipping point as the scientists
describe it do we really need another
prize is that going to
bring about the change that we need we
hope so i mean the idea being that we we
very much felt that
what was needed what was missing at the
moment was very much a case of
harnessing people's optimism and
people's hope
there's been a lot of negativity and
pessimism and i think
it's it's such a big scale topic that
people themselves don't know you know
if i recycle my plastic every single day
actually how much of a big difference am
i making
and i think a lot of people out there
want to see the next level they want to
see several levels go because
this is an ambitious prize it's a it's
an ambitious target and topic we're
dealing with
and we can make the difference if we
really put our minds together and we
come together and
harness the human ingenuity and and
spirit of
finding solutions you're certainly not
the first member of the family to talk
about
this subject you've recently talked
about edinburgh and the prince of wales
and their commitment to the environment
um how much have you spoken to them
about this prize and what was their
reaction to what you're doing
so obviously as you all know my
grandfather was a bit of a trailblazer a
long time ago
and i did a lot with the wwf in nature
long before it was sort of fashionable
or noticeable to do it my father
obviously has been about climate change
for many many years
and so i felt i sort of feel there's a
bit of a family history to sort of
inherit in in terms of the environment
but
i think each generation passes on
something crucial to the next one to
follow on
and i feel that really for me to avoid
getting into and helping the environment
is a real
mistake and this is me kind of putting
my stamp on
what i can do is in my position to
really galvanize
and increase the interest and tackle
some of these issues to really
drive a decade of change to repair the
planet we've spoken before about
how sometimes it's difficult to choose
what subjects you decide to stick your
head above the parapet
about your father has been accused at
times
being too political when it comes to
this subject how concerned are you that
you might face the same criticism
i think with all things in life if you
are willing to make a difference you
have to put yourself out there and you
have to
um commit yourself and be determined and
maybe go places that you might feel
uncomfortable other people might find
uncomfortable but
really for me the prize is about
bringing people together you know it's a
team
it's a team prize and if we can really
harness everyone's ability to come
together and tackle
the earth's biggest environmental
problems then i think the prize is the
right way of doing it because you're
rewarding you're incentivizing and
you're encouraging
so you're bringing about hope and we
feel hope and optimism
as part of this team is the real the
only way we're going to actually
progress
of course absolutely i'm sure people
will challenge that question and the
more debate about it we have we welcome
that
and and like i said this is a team prize
so if there are people out there who
think they can do it better they can
help with this then please come on board
and
we'd love that the fact that you're
talking about
trying to drive some kind of optimism um
within this sphere and within the debate
how much is that
inspired by the conversations that you
have with your own children
about it because you look at the world
and actually we are in a
dire state and it is fairly depressing
why do you think it's so important
that we have that optimism and how much
do you try and bring that into the
discussions
i think to be perfectly honest i'm
struggling to keep the optimism levels
going with my own children
and that's really kind of like a self uh
honest understanding moment where you
kind of look at yourself and go am i
doing enough on this are we really at
this stage in life where
i can't be hugely optimistic and and
pleased that my children are getting so
into nature
um because you kind of worry and dread
that they're soon going to realize that
we're in a very very
dangerous and difficult time in the
environment and that and as a parent you
feel like you're letting them down
immediately
so having watched so many david
attenborough documentaries recently with
with my children they absolutely love
them
the most recent one the extinction one
actually george and i had to turn it off
we got so sad about it halfway through
and he said to me he said you know i
don't want to watch this anymore it's
just why is it why does it come to this
and you know he's seven years old and
he's asking me these questions already
he really feels it
and i think every seven-year-old out
there can relate to that so i really
feel
from an emotional point of view as well
i think every parent everyone wants to
do the best for their children and i
think
we have to have a decade of of change a
decade of repairing the planets that we
can hand it on to the next generation
and
future generations and sustain the
prosperity
for their lives too the earth shock
prize obviously spans
ten years your children be teenagers by
then
um how do you think you will gauge
whether it's been the success that you
see hope it's going to be
well we have set ourselves ambitious
earth shots each year
so we've got five earth shots per year
for 10 years
so that's basically tackling climate
nature air oceans and waste
and we through a number of panels and
experts we all agreed that this was the
the key crux areas that we had to
challenge if we can find solutions
so we're looking roughly 50 solutions
over the next 10 years that can really
turn the tide and really change
the way we deal and tackle with
environmental challenges then we would
have it would have been a success and
it'd been worth it
but as with the moonshot landings with
jfk when he you know had that
that vision to put a man on the moon it
was called the moonshot we've adapted
that to call it the earth shot to sort
of
you know harness that ingenuity idea we
very much
hope that even if we can't necessarily
change the world in 10 years time just
from the prize alone
what we do hope is just like the
moonshot landings we can you know where
they developed
cat scanners x-ray machines uh breathing
apparatus
stuff like that i think um has been
really really important to
to come out of that so we hope that
environmentally we can still produce
some really big solutions even if we
can't necessarily ourselves just as the
prize
change everything in 10 years time one
final one because i know that you've got
to go and you're very busy
um but i wanted to get your thoughts
because i actually have to father the
fritz wells
about this at the end of lockdown what
do you think that the kobit 19 pandemic
has taught us
as a world about what we can do when we
face a crisis
that actually is a global global issue
i think certainly for my generation and
and those
below i don't think we've ever faced
anything like this um obviously previous
generations have gone through the world
wars and
and times that were far tougher than
what they are now but we are going
through a certain period of time where
families are being restricted seeing
each other uh jobs are being lost
it's difficult for everybody um but the
spirit of togetherness and the
ability to fight back i think is one of
the you know one of the humans
kind of biggest elements and i do think
it's brought us closer together i think
we're all in a shared
similar situation if we can take that
forward into the environment and and
replicate that you know we found over
190 billion pounds worth to
fix and help uh the recovery through
covert
we can do the same for environment it
really isn't that difficult and
and i went to oxford and saw the
vaccination you know attempts
and watching the cross governmental
cross-country nash international kind of
uh collaborations coming together to
find a vaccine for everyone
that was hugely inspiring and it shows
you if we if we want to do it
we can do it thank you so much